[Musique]
bonjour didier borniche bonjour vous
êtes le président de l'ordre national
des infirmiers de passage aux antilles
jusqu'en fin de semaine didier borniche
infirmiers infirmières métier en
souffrance ce métier une profession qui
rime avec épuisement oui aujourd'hui
malheureusement notre profession fait
l'actualité depuis quelques mois puisque
nous avons eu à déplorer la disparition
par suicide de six professionnels de
santé depuis moins d'un an
ce qui caractérise l'état d'épuisement
morale et physique de notre profession à
l'heure actuelle et le mal-être qu'elle
ressent épuisement physique épuisement
psychique mentale quelles sont les
raisons de ce malaise des blouses
blanches
alors ces raisons sont multiples et
variées dans le cadre notamment des
établissements hospitaliers il est un
événement qui en considération qui est
le plan les plans de retour à
l'équilibré des établissements
hospitaliers qui sont tous dans les
conditions financières dramatiques et
qui ont pris comme variable comme une
des variables d'ajustement de leur
situation financière
les effectifs dont il dispose et
notamment les effectifs infirmiers c'est
à dire qu'aujourd'hui les infirmiers et
infirmières doivent malheureusement
faire toujours plus avec toujours moins
en mettant en danger la qualité et la
sécurité des soins et en mettant
quelques fois aussi en jeu leur propre
vie malheureusement il ya quinze jours
encore un professionnel s'est suicidée à
paris
ça montre combien cette profession va
mal aujourd'hui
ces mauvaises conditions de travail sont
telles évoqué or plus haut lieu au
niveau du ministère de la santé par
exemple écouter pour tout vous dire nous
avions une réunion hier matin avec le
ministère de la santé avec nos collègues
d'autres professions de santé dont les
médecins pour évoquer ces sujets est
envisagée avec les tutelles des mesures
de prévention pour mieux prendre en
charge
c'est ces événements qui sont absolument
inacceptables
aujourd'hui en tout cas l'ordre national
des infirmiers et sur un sujet qui le
préoccupe beaucoup et la profession doit
savoir que son ordre
aujourd'hui est à ses côtés pour l'aider
à travers les difficultés qu'elles
rencontrent dix bornes et je vous
évoquez également les déficits de
reconnaissance aux de déficit de
reconnaissance de la part de qui de
cette autorité de tutelle de la part des
autres professions de la part de la
population
nous sommes face à une situation
extrêmement paradoxal les infirmiers et
les infirmières de notre pays sont avec
les sapeurs pompiers la profession la
plus populaire qui existe c'est celle
qui jouit de la plus grande sympathie
vis à vis de la population et c'est
celle qui par l'occe allemand est
probablement la plus maltraitée le plus
mal payé aussi parallèlement
effectivement aujourd'hui on ne peut pas
considérer que cette profession soient
rémunérés à la hauteur des
responsabilités qu'elle a et tout cela
concourt à jaillir majorer le malaise
que nous ressentons il faut absolument
que nos tutelles nos politiques
c'est ça vaut 16 d'avoir comme je les
écris récemment beaucoup d'empathie
vis-à-vis de nous l'empathie c'est
sympathique c'est bien ça mais les tapes
dans le dos mais c'est pas suffisant
nous ce que nous voulons aujourd'hui ce
sont des véritables geste positif
vis-à-vis de cette profession qui a
comme préoccupation principale et je ne
veux pas que mes propos soient ici pris
comme étant les propos corporatiste qui
a comme principale préoccupation la
qualité et la sécurité des soins de nos
concitoyens nous sommes aujourd'hui
vraiment au plus près
des soins des patients est le premier
maillon justement de la chaîne de santé
absolument nous sommes celui et celle
qui au quotidien reste aux côtés des
patients
jusque au dernier moment de la vie
d'ailleurs didier borniche est-ce que
vous est ce que vous pouvez
au niveau de l'ordre informé par exemple
ces nouvelles générations qui voudraient
embrassé ce métier d'infirmier
d'infirmier à souhait leur dis attention
c'est peut-être une très belle
profession mais les conditions de
travail sont très difficile qu'est ce
que vous pouvez faire à ce niveau là
écoutez pour tout vous dire j'étais hier
matin à l'institut de formation soin
infirmier du chu ici à fort-de-france où
nous avons échangé avec nos futurs
collègues toute la matinée sont
forcément des sujets que nous abordons
ensemble c'est une profession qui jouit
d'une dune grande une grande sympathie à
l'intérieur de notre oui mais la réalité
la réalité mais la vrai lorsqu'on a les
mains dans le cambouis ya sur la réalité
elle est totalement différente c'est
quand que vous commencez à rentrer aux
côtés des patients me hospitaliers
publics ou privés d'ailleurs ou par la
suite dans le milieu libéral est bien là
vous découvrez une autre facette qui
sont les dures réalités de notre
exercice professionnel avec des rythmes
de travail qui sont absolument
insoutenable avec d une considération
qui n'est pas à la hauteur de ce que
nous attendons avec des contraintes qui
sont de plus en plus importante
et d'ailleurs je pense que nous aurons
l'occasion d'en reparler
juste après la sortie notre code de
déontologie de mayari faux janvier
j'allais dire renforcer notre position
les élèves infirmiers il garde toujours
cette flamme dans les yeux dans ce que
lorsque vous évoquez ces réalités des
conditions d'exercice du travail oui oui
il garde on l'a vu hier matin avec tous
ces étudiants une centaine d'étudiants
que nous avions en face de nous il y à
cette flamme et tant mieux
il faut qu'elle perdure parce que notre
pays a besoin de ces jeunes générations
qui vont prendre
notre relève pour assurer la qualité des
soins et la sécurité de nos patients
l'exercice de l'équilibré quand même
assez délicat entre la ces mauvaises
conditions de travail cette mauvaise
reconnaissance et puis et puis les
salaires qui ne sont pas toujours au
rendez-vous comment comment s'assurer de
l'attractivité d'une profession mais je
pense que la balle aujourd'hui elle est
dans le camp de nos politiques
il faut qu'ils aient de l'ambition pour
nos concitoyens pour mieux les prendre
en charge
je crois qu'aujourd'hui on ne peut pas
on peut pas se contenter de belles
paroles
nous étions invités récemment par un des
candidats à la présidentielle qui nous a
beaucoup parlé de prévention et quand
nous avons évoqué avec lui les moyens
qui pourraient être mis derrière la
prévention ça c'était une coquille vide
semble-t-il donc nous ce que nous
voulons aujourd'hui c'est à dire quel
candidat non par sympathie on en a
d'autres à rencontrer et après on
viendra sur ces sujets mais les idées
borne est justement puisque nous sommes
dans dans le temps de cette campagne
pour la présidentielle dans le temps de
cette campagne également pour les
législatives c'est à dire les députés
ceux qui font des doigts
est ce que vous êtes surpris par
l'absence de ce secteur santé dans
l'oeil dans les propos des uns et des
autres mais vous savez on qu'on étende
une période où nous allons nous nourrir
de promesses
et puis on sait ce qu'elles deviennent
malheureusement par la suite d'euros
connaît la chanson
voilà donc nous ce que nous ce que nous
voulons c'est à travers une plateforme
politique que nous sommes d'ailleurs en
train de mettre en place et qui va dans
la journée eux mêmes être adressée à
l'ensemble des professionnels inscrits
au tableau c'est aller vers les
politiques en leur disant maintenant des
actions maintenant des actions sur le
terrain nous avons besoin que les
professionnels dans les services ne
soient plus considérés comme des
variables d'ajustement économique
nous avons besoin que les ratios de
personnel soit mise en place de façon à
ce que l'épuisement et le burn out dont
nous sommes victimes au quotidien
disparaissent nous avons besoin d'être
considérés et nous avons besoin que
l'empathie soient transformés anges
ange atteindra les organismes terrestres
ordre tous et toutes ces personnes qui
disent
depuis leur bureau les amener sur le
terrain pour leur montrer comment ça
fonctionne mais malheureusement c'est ce
n'est pas propre à notre profession
c'est très bien aujourd'hui que nous
vivons dans l'ère de la technocratie et
que ce sont les technocrates qui dirige
et qui sont les têtes bien pensantes
dans notre pays
le bon sens aujourd'hui a disparu nous
demandons qu'ils reviennent alors vous
avez évoqué ce code de déontologie de la
profession c'est un texte qui est qui
est sorti en fin d'année dernière au
mois de novembre
son objectif c'est quoi mais écoutez son
objectif c'est de donner à notre
profession la place qu'elle mérite
pour la première fois notre profession à
son code de déontologie près de soixante
dix ans après celui des médecins ou les
sages femmes
nous sommes dotés de nos propres règles
d'exercice professionnel il en avait
certaines qui existaient précédemment
dans le col de la santé publique elle
daté de 1993 et donc ses règles enfin
ses règles ses codes de déontologie doit
marquer la reconnaissance de l'ensemble
d'une profession vers une plus grande
autonomie ça c'est fondamental
il faut améliorer également les
relations avec les patients avec les
autres corps de métiers de ce secteur de
santé c'est difficile ce relationnel
avec les autres professions santé non
très sincèrement en tout cas notre ordre
les meilleures relations du monde temps
j'allais dire dans l'est dans les
régions que national avec d'autres
professions il n'en demeure pas moins
que parfois nous pourrons avoir des
points de vue divergents
ça a été le cas récemment par exemple
quand on a parlé de la vaccination qui
pourrait être fait par les pharmaciens
ou qui sera fait à titre expérimental
par les pharmaciens et pour laquelle
nous d'ailleurs nous demandons que les
infirmiers et infirmières de ce pays qui
sont formés qui ont les compétences
puissent le faire et que nos collègues
libéraux qui font qu'ils sont encore les
seuls professionnels de santé allaient
encore domicile des patients puissent
pratiquer ses actes alors non nous
n'avons pas de difficultés
relationnelles
nous plaçons comme je vous l'aï dit tout
à l'heure le patient au coeur de nos
préoccupations et ce code de déontologie
il marque vraiment ce point là puisque
le mot patient revient quasiment dans
tous les articles de notre code qui
comporte 80 nous article alors un code
paru au mois de novembre est ce
qu'aujourd'hui tous les professionnels
connaissent le contenu de ce code ce
qu'ils l'aient été s qui était adoptée à
100% est ce qu'il ya des réticences
peut-être alors ce code il a été d'abord
l'objet d'une très large concertation de
la profession dans les départements dans
les régions
pendant plusieurs mois et il est le
fruit de cette concertation
ce code il a été dicté par un décret en
conseil d'état et donc aujourd'hui il
est applicable à l'ensemble de la
profession que la profession ne le
connaissent pas ça ne fait pas l'ombre
d'un doute elle est en train de cela de
se l'approprier
nous avions une réunion hier soir avec
une centaine d'infirmières libérales de
martinique est le thème de la soirée
c'était justement le code et notre logis
pour les aider à s'approprier ce code
qui les concerne également merci didier
borniche de la vérité avec toi rappelle
que vous êtes le président national de
l'ordre des infirmiers merci d'arrêter
ce matin avec nous dans son crédit bonne
journée
[Musique]